Jean Boulet est le ministre du Travail
de l'Emploi de la solidarité sociale de
l'immigration de la francisation et de
l'intégration j'ai pas mal de travail
monsieur boulet bonsoir bonsoir Monsieur
comment allez-vous ça va bien écouté
aujourd'hui vous annoncer donc le plein
le plein de match pour la rareté de main
d'oeuvre et vous annoncer donc une
allocation de 475 dollars par semaine
pour les personnes sans emploi pour
aller pour qu'ils aillent se faire
former en quelques sortes vous visez qui
exactement
comme vous le mentionner les personnes
qui ont pas d'emploi donc ils sont des
prestataires d'assurance chômage ou des
prestataires d'aide sociale on anticipe
à peu près de 9000 travailleurs
travailleuses au Québec qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ce montant d'argent là
pour suivre des programmes de formation
et réintégrer le marché de l'emploi dans
un peu prés tous les 7 et donc 475
dollars par semaine pour étudier pendant
qu'on y est
c'est jusqu'à un maximum de 48 semaines
ok donc des programmes sont plus court
de 6 mois un an et demi mais je pense
que tu en es où au niveau professionnel
que collégiens les mêmes universités les
personnes vont pouvoir donc bénéficier
de ce montant là et se faire former ou
requalifié ou si le reste de résultats
si au bout de 48 semaines une personne a
touché le 475 par semaine et retourne à
la maison tout simplement il se passe
quoi le pot double ration de
remboursement c'est un montant d'argent
moi j'appelle sonne mesure active qui
permet à la personne d'entreprendre un
parcours de formation évidemment il va y
avoir un suivi non on n'a pas
l'intention de réclamer des montant
d'argent pour les personnes qui auraient
pas compléter le parcours évidemment
c'est ce qu'on souhaite ok c'est pas la
formation pour tous les travailleurs
travailleuses qui n'ont pas d'emploi
c'est la même chose pour les bourses
vous allez payer les études des
étudiants dans certains secteurs 1500
part
2500 à l'université mais au bout de
leurs études il est pas dit qu'il se
rend dans ces secteurs là il est qui
vend combler précisément des emplois
dans les acteurs en pénurie il y a des
promesse d'embauche et les montants de
bourse de 15 100 dollars ou 2500 quand
on est au niveau universitaire seront
versés uniquement quand la session sera
complétée sur sa session absolument
contre la session soit complété ok
qu'elle soit réussi mais au bout des
études en se passe de toute façon on
sait jamais quand on voit l'université
si ça va se passer très exactement comme
on pensait à la sortie d'université
279000 postes vacants en septembre c'est
les dernières donner un monsieur boulet
de Sète - Canada
oui évidemment c'est un
pdf sur les postes vacants ce qui
mensuel dans le corps du mois de
septembre le dernier PVs qui
trimestrielle avril je fais
294145 postes ok et on me dit que la
prochaine la prochaine étude
trimestrielle sera présenté le 20
décembre prochain ok parfait on se le
dit quand même le vous êtes à 170.000
travailleur sur 5 ans je ne sais pas
jusqu'à quel point la pénurie va prendre
de l'ampleur au cours des prochains mois
des prochains trimestres des prochaines
années est-ce qu'on est pas loin du
compte par rapport aux besoins du marché
du travail il faut mentionner que c'est
170.000 travailleur qualifié additionnel
donc c'est 110.000 dans les secteurs
privés technologies de l'information le
génie et la construction et 60 miles
dans les services essentiels public
évidemment on a des priorités il faut
assurer la continuité des services
essentielle pour soigner le malade faut
prendre soin de nos enfants aussi bien
sûr et donc dans les services les
connais identifié la santé l'éducation
les services de garde on est en les
femmes on est qualifié c'est des
personnes qui participe à des à des
parcours de formation un certain homme
ou si tu décides de se réorienter ok
donc de se qualifier souvenez-vous le
programme de requalifier
qu'on avait lancé et appliquée l'année
dernière il y a contribué à requalifier
21500 travailleur au Québec et on en a
un qui est amorcée spécifiquement dans
les technologies de l'information et on
anticipe pouvoir requalifier 6500
personnes dans ce secteur l'heure vous
le savez qui névralgie quelle économie
du Québec est-ce que je comprends dans
les propos du Premier ministre dans vos
propos des propos du gouvernement que
les entreprises ou les secteurs
d'activité qui n'arrive pas à commenter
leur salaire et qui n'arrive pas à
améliorer les conditions salariales mais
tant pis pour eux les travailleurs Iran
se faire former pour aller dans ton
secteur
non pas forcément vous savez que les
vous les ateliers pas ces secteurs qui
sont en difficulté vous établissez les
secteurs stratégiques qui est important
mais les secteurs sculpté qui ont du mal
à monter les salaires si vous prenez les
exemples d'humaniste commerce de détail
transformation alimentaire hôtellerie
restauration hébergement on est des
mesures d'accompagnement une offensive
de transformation numérique il y a de la
formation en automatisation à
robotisation et aussi des programmes de
formation en alternance travail-études
qu'on ne lancer un certain nombre
d'années qui donne des résultats et
pressione en particulièrement dans le
secteur manufacturier on a fait une
entente avec Ottawa pour élargir le
bassin des travailleurs étrangers
temporaire ok dans les secteurs que je
viens de vous mentionner ça s'appelait
et un programme de mobilité
internationale une addition de solution
Dépôt plus de ça vous l'avez fait
aujourd'hui là c'est pas dans le plan
pour réduire la rareté
belle demeure à 50.000
travailler à notre capacité
d'intégration année ces personnes dans
les régions où il y a des besoins
concret mais pour limitation temporaire
le bassin être considérablement cru
qu'on le fait une entente avec ta voix
pour un programme de mobilité
internationale qui vont nous permettre
d'accélérer la venue de travailler avec
sont à l'étranger qualifié si on dit
certificat de sélection du Quebec et ça
ça doit être bénéfique aussi pour
contribuer à la lutte à la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci Monsieur s'il y en a
bientôt pouvoir nous émission en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI